tonight millions of sports fans will
tune in to their first major event in
six weeks as the NFL Draft kicks off and
for the first time the draft will take
place virtually with Commissioner Roger
Goodell announcing picks from his
basement
it comes as sports leagues around the
world grapple with how to return after a
corona virus cancellations in our series
on the new normal CBS this morning
Saturday co-anchor Dana Jacobson shows
us what fans might expect I'm tired of
watching baseball games at a 14 years
old from president Truong I think having
them play on television is certainly
better than nothing - dr. Anthony foul a
3-2 that desire to see live sports again
is clear but the path to getting there
is a bit murkier it's actually NHL
commissioner Gary Bettman is just one
executive trying to steer his sport
through an unknown landscape if we can
play in a small window without fans if
we need to go to centralized locations
with no fans and modify the schedule
we'll do that we will is agile and
adaptable Bettman and fellow
commissioners from both team and
individual sports have had ongoing
discussions with President Trump about
an inevitable return pro sports like
hockey basketball and golf had their
seasons paused by the pandemic while
others like baseball have yet to start
Batman says for all sports health and
testing are the top priorities it's one
getting the number of tests you need to
be comfortable you're doing the right
things together and two we don't want to
be in a situation where we're depriving
the medical community of the tests that
they may need to deal with people who
13-year NFL veteran coleus Campbell is a
member of the NFL Players Association
Executive Committee what is your biggest
concern about the idea of sports going
forward
the world that were in now he also says
health is a concern for players to in
the NFL have tested positive including
his close friend Von Miller does it hit
a little closer to home when you see
guys like yourself healthy pro athletes
catching the virus as well going back to
work decide well I mean these guys know
we should all be sick you might even
know it you know you know and that's
pretty scary but while every sport is
different Campbell believes no matter
how each comes back with fans full
without its usual reason the whole you
know everybody has a team they want to
hold wins the game or you know go Z was
the championship and that's what makes
for special so you know I really do will
be beneficial for a lot of people right
now going through tough times
you know just bring them back something
to get those pro sports backs leagues
really are considering everything from
neutral sites to limited sites and of
course no fans as for return dates with
Major League Baseball nothing concrete
yet the NBA and NHL say that they can
play well into summer to finish the
regular season which is the priority the
NFL obviously has some time and the PGA
Tour is targeting a June return without
fans but they do say Tony that that is
contingent again on having all the
testing necessary which would mean for
the players the caddies and all the
support personnel as well yeah so
important to get it right but also Dana
is so important to get it back I miss
sports as much as everybody thank you
very much